few funds epitomize the huge bull market
in technology stocks and the recent
vicious sell-off quite like chase
coleman's tiger global
a favorite protege of legendary hedge
fund manager julian robertson coleman
set up his new york-based firm in 2001
during the bursting of the dot-com
bubble which saw the nasdaq plunge in
value
drawing on his mentor's hugely
successful investing style he hunted for
companies with strong positions in an
industry and high barriers to entry
valuations while important could be a
secondary consideration chinese internet
stocks overlooked by western investors
were a source of early gains
coleman's strategy proved highly
effective its punchy bets on the growth
of tech firms both listed and private
helped it become one of the world's most
successful hedge fund and private equity
firms
assets swelled to around 90 billion
dollars
by the start of 2021 coleman featured in
lch investments list of the top
performing hedge fund managers of all
time above star names such as steve
cohen alan howard and lewis bacon but
tiger global style has recently fallen
badly out of favor
rising interest rates have made tech
companies with projected cash flows far
in the future less appealing
valuations have plummeted
its hedge fund which suffered big losses
on holdings such as peloton posted a
seven percent loss last year
much worse was to come
this year to the end of may it lost a
further 52
that erased the majority of the dollar
gains it had made for investors since
launch more than 20 years ago
so far investors appear to be backing
coleman whose fund has cut fees this
year he told investors he believes the
loss is mark one point in time on a long
journey and is committed to making them
back
doing that will surely prove the
toughest test of his career
yet
[Music]